February 2023 Nintendo Direct finally
dropped the biggest trailer to date and
while we still have no clue what the
game is actually about they at least
showed us way more of Hyrule in this
trailer than any other trailer to date
so let's go back shot by shot and break
down everything we see here in the
upcoming tears of the Kingdom
the first shots start off fairly slow
only showing us a couple new things this
angle facing death Mountain from Mabe
Prairie shows more spiral patterns on
the ground that we've seen in previous
trailers the lightning also has a slight
green tinge usually lightning has a more
off-whiteish color so this may not be
your average thunderstorm throughout the
trailer there's dozens of examples of
strange Boulders piles of malice and new
buildings that repeat themselves so I
won't go too much into that since we
already know that the land of Hyrule has
changed quite a bit the military
training camp next to korok Forest
without the shika Tower is now infested
with new Longhorn goblins and a new
flying enemy type we've seen in a
previous trailer as well previously
thought to be cargo rocks these seem to
be entirely new enemies since they seem
to be plentiful in Hyrule by the amount
of times they show up in this trailer
there are likely to be our new common
annoyance while traveling downwards or
upwards and will likely get into lots of
aerial combat with them the area between
tabanta and Heber range is shown next
with two shining Towers attached with
spotlights we also get a closer look of
a circling storm surrounding hebra Peak
with another ground design seen from
previous trailers the purpose of these
still goes unexplained do keep in mind
though the tower's shapes and colors
because we will see them again later in
the video one last thing to point out is
that Val Meadow is missing from its
perch on top of Reno Village so we still
don't know what happened to the Divine
beasts it starts to pick up a bit from
here as we get to see some strange
ground formations that are completely
unique to breath of the wild besides
this Square platform here and the ground
symbol from the previous shot you can
also see the structure north of Giza
crater sitting on top of kuho mountain
with a round Center and sections that
jut off in different directions this is
interesting because this is one of the
largest new structures we've seen on the
ground floor so far with every trailer
underground exploration became teased
more and more and now it's a confirmed
reality in this shot we see a longhorn
Goblin with a backpack and a rock hammer
chipping away at a piece of ore while
they can't see upwards to confirm a
cavern ceiling you can pretty much
confirm it from the background audio
here
[Music]
which has Reverb to match its Cavern
setting which is a new addition audio
wise since even breath of the wild
underground location did not account for
this kind of audio
see Longhorn lesolfos equipped with
throwing Spears and Lysol bows covered
in Rising malice likely all empowered by
the new villain besides the new
vegetation and structures in the
background blue fire dodged the ground
on the right side these willow wisp type
fires could possibly be Poe but are more
likely to be something seen before in
Twilight Princess Souls as seen in the
Twilight realm we've seen multiple
Twilight and Skyward references in
previous trailers so at some point we'll
see how this all connects this shot from
hylia Island looking out towards Hyrule
castle and Death Mountain has a couple
notable features on the left you can see
a new structure on top of this hill and
what looks like an opening into the
hillside likely leading down into an
underground area on the right side is a
monstrous creature that is likely to be
a glioc a multi-headed dragon that spits
out fire from Zelda 1. we also see a
glimpse of a blue Tower behind the gliac
which we'll get back to in just a second
this camera angle overlooks hatano
Village looking Southwest towards the
Faron region again we see another
spiral-like structure and new glowing
teepee like building starting the main
village with no explanation on what they
are one last thing in this shot to mull
over is that Overworld chica technology
is still clearly missing the ancient
furnace is gone chica towers and shrines
are still absent but something is
strange here again this blue structure
in the far background near courage step
is highly likely to be the same
structure as the red orange Tower seen
here before so this may mean that
unlocking shika technology may still
play a key role in the sequel even
though it's not a major mechanic anymore
the next several shots show a Blood Moon
turning into a dark Crimson before
supposed Ganon launches an attack
against Hyrule Hyrule Castle itself has
a large crust of malice surrounding it
as well as the bridge to Zelda study
completely broken then a volley of
malice souls are sent towards the gray
Plateau Landing south of Mount hylia but
something is amiss here this South Wall
does not appear in the game like this
it's completely covered in snow and
damaged here so it's possible this cut
scene occurred in the past and breath of
the Wild's great Plateau is the
aftermath many years later an explosion
follows up but this is a different
cutscene entirely as the ground looks to
be the wide Sandy areas of the Gerudo
desert what's enveloped in the explosion
is a mystery though as we can only make
out a large enemy with what looks like
four guardian-like arms and massive
claws magma-filled rocks then begin to
crumble likely a separate event from
this Castle crumbling scene as far as we
can tell death Mountain's lava seems to
be inactive so we'll see how lava and
magma in general plays a role in tears
of the Kingdom the gray Plateau appears
again and a couple things can be picked
here simple things like the Shiga Tower
missing and another set of ground
designs appear again but you can also
catch things like more flat patches of
malice near previously Omen owl Shrine
and the previous shot of the gliac
guarding the bridge of hylia is nowhere
to be found multiple Guardian bodies
litter this pool side and breath of the
wild while they are completely missing
here whether it's related to time chica
technology absence or some other event
it's still unexplained so again we'll
have to wait and see we see a follow-up
shot to the blood moon we saw before
with bokoblins coming to life out of the
Blobs of malice that come down equipped
with serrated horns instead of the
normal Longhorns we've seen so far they
land right on top of the gray Plateau
wall then we see many of hyrule's new
monsters with several newcomers first we
see the new Big Book hoblins according
to the official Zelda Japan Twitter
they're simply called boss bakoblins
then we get our first look at tears of
the Kingdom's redead a zombie-like
creature that has appeared in most major
Zelda titles seeing as they have a
history of creepily latching onto link
I'm not looking forward to seeing that
again with these terrifying new Jaws the
bakabla and lizalthos also sport new
horn pieces link is then seen riding
near Hyrule Castle on what looks like
Epona which is interesting because Epona
was not easy to make Canon into the
story of breath of the wild since it was
locked behind an amiibo making Epona
Cannon now would make us wonder what the
opponent amiibo will be used for now but
we'll have to see we again see a
circling storm above hebra and possibly
a new building in front of the Hyrule
Castle Gates on the left then we see a
shot of the great Plateau looking down
upon osira planes and what looks like a
malice wildfire in the distance it's
hard to tell from this distance but
there may be a moldugo's head sticking
out of the ground here link then stands
on top of a travel gate getting
surrounded by guardian-like arms with
guide rails on the side that likely make
this elevator go upwards one arm in
front of Link holds a spool hooked to a
wire that feeds from the platform below
but we have no idea why it's handing
this device to link from what I'm seeing
here I personally get some Robbie or
poorer vibes from this cutscene possibly
handing equipment to link to help them
set up a device this is also one of the
first times we see Guardian technology
back in tears the Kingdom so this may be
Robbie or purus fiddling another
important thing to point out is the
chico platform itself this is not a
chica Tower travel gate rather this is
the Divine Beast travel gate which has
the same inscription as well since these
are only found on Divine beasts and
Zelda stated in the secret breath of the
wild ending that Divine Beast valruta
has stopped working and all Divine
beasts are missing sing from tears of
the Kingdom this may have been Salvage
Tech ripped right off a Divine Beast
which yet again sounds like something
Pura or Robbie would do this next
location is a Baobab Tree area between
the Gerudo Highlands and Satori Mountain
we then see a pack of book hoblins with
the boss book hoblin ready for battle
the weapon is hard to make out but from
the small details we see the boss
bakoblin is wielding a malice corrupted
two-handed soldiers Claymore in one hand
tears of the Kingdom also seems to be
ramping up its enemy with enemy teamwork
interactions such as as possible Goblin
commanding all the Goblins to attack at
once it may become a situation where
taking on a leader will cause the enemy
Squad to become uncoordinated something
similar to Halo games with Grunts and
Elites
another really interesting thing to
point out here is that they're using an
asset that we never got in breath of the
wild the scrapped metal horn from the
book creating a champion this was in
development in the first game as a
Lionel horn but never made it into the
final release now this metal horn comes
to life in the hands of this new enemy
High knocks make a return to tears in
the Kingdom this one's sporting some
sort of jelly-like substance on his
necklace and a silly looking hat link
then takes us on a couple landscape
shots over the serious scablands and a
close-up on the ground design of the
north Hyrule plane again in every shot
there seems to be slightly altered
terrain everywhere so I won't go
pointing out every single one the next
shot points us Eastward between korok
forest and high flow ruins we also get
to see another enemy with enemy
interaction with these new flying types
carrying the goblets between the talus
Fort filled with the cobbler snipers the
goblin coordinated attacks and these
flying types carrying by goblins tears
of the kingdom is definitely ramping up
its enemy intelligence in interesting
ways looking Southwest from Samosa plain
we see a moblin picking itself up while
I initially thought that this was a
normal getup animation it's actually the
tail end of a new headbutt attack which
makes sense with this terrifying new
helmet that it's sporting as the camera
pans left we see a glimpse of a new
enemy skull encampment with scaffolding
on top and this time with a nose a
towering new blocky zonai enemy then
attacks link you can see the dragon type
Inspirations on the blocks on its arms I
imagine these blocks may be climbable
and this would go down similarly to a
Shadow of the Colossus fight with its
shiny weak point conveniently placed up
high we then see more missing shots from
the cutscene of the supposed Ganondorf
waking up out of his Slumber while it's
slightly more context it's just more
shots of the same situation shown in
previous trailers more shots of the open
world from right near death mountain and
while we constantly see new islands in
the background of each new trailer this
shot has many of them together such as
this massive Cube and the multi-level
Island link skydived yet again dropping
down around the dueling Peaks area from
here you can see this pool of malice
north of Bremen Peak and the same
strange Tower poking out of the Faron
region again going for a nice hike along
safra's slope it's mostly more of the
same things just seen before ground
designs cubes in the sky towers and an
upgraded enemy camp next to knobby Lake
Link then shoots at a balloon type Arrow
which automatically homes in on the
enemy it's hard to tell if it's Link's
new arm that enables this ability but
light green energy does charge up before
the shot the fact that this
automatically goes for the head for
critical damage could be great for
making non-bullet time headshots count
Shield surfing makes a return and
seemingly being able to magnetically
attach to metal rails this is on Death
Mountain by the way which since it's an
active and filled with malice can be
walked around without fireproof gear now
but goblin here wields a rusty Claymore
more mining cards with no bomb cages
since we don't have remote bombs anymore
wooded walls likely to block Shield
surfing but can be rammed through with
carts and a moblin Archer while moblins
did carry bows before they never had the
Sentry job of being a lookout for enemy
encampments so this will be a first for
them there are also suspicious looking
wheels or fans placed in several spots
with shots coming later that could mean
something big link then grabs a gyro
with this new skill their arm hasn't
shown yet a telekinesis type ability
this is likely to replace magnesia since
well we don't have the Chica slate
anymore link then does a two-handed
jumping attack with the strange weapon
we think that this is actually two
different items the staff may be 1 piece
attached to a cannon at the end but
there's no concrete evidence yet one
thing we could point out is that the
same broom logo found here is found on
this creature as well in a previous
trailer so there may be some sort of
connection to this power symbol then a
mysterious lady appears with the amount
of information that we have there is no
way to pinpoint who this is theories
such as Zelda Helia herself or someone
else entirely will just have to wait and
see again link uses telekinesis to lift
up a mechanical wheel out of the great
plateau's mud pit and you can make out a
new style of treasure chests on this
tiny little island then link appears on
a car on a hot air balloon and on a
hovercraft by the way they're presenting
this these machines seem to be buildable
depending on pieces that you find during
your adventures especially since the
base portion with vertical handlebars
and white platform are shared across
each machine the headlights on here are
also the same egg flower shape found on
this robot in the previous trailer we
then finally arrive at this shot of Link
possibly riding oppona riding Eastward
several malice pools dot the left side
along with the Hylian encampment it
funny thing is after five trailers this
is the first time we ever seen NPC
Nintendo is really keeping their cards
close to their chest when it comes to
any other characters and tears of the
kingdom and this is the most we've ever
gotten on that front a piece of Island
falls from the sky confirming again our
suspicion of using time reversal on
Fallen pieces to rise upwards the last
shot shows again more context to how the
initial showdown between link Zelda and
this Ganondorf figure went you could see
malice grip the masked sword from the
very first strike in the previous
trailer and as Ganondorf goes for a
second helping link then drops the
master sword and goes to save Princess
Zelda which we all know how that went
Nintendo then decided to release a few
screenshots and social media posts that
showed just a tad more with key ones
like this picture of Zelda with possibly
a chica slate the Chica slate and breath
of the wild was based roughly on the Wii
U gamepad so just a small theory is that
this could be a re-engineered slate from
Pura Robbie using a body of a switch to
keep up with the times this also
possibly could prove that Zelda survived
the fall and has some gameplay
implications another snapshot shows a
wider Sky Island's landscape that
clearly shows farage in the distance and
the zonai creature again but with the
square platform on the side which is
shown on this shot as well amiibos will
also unlock special paraglider skins
while a ton of new features were shown
here we still don't know what is
happening in the game who the new
characters are where the NPCs are how
combat mechanics are returning and much
much more so we'll likely have to wait
until one last trailer for The Grand
reveal before the game's launch on May
12 2023. if you enjoyed this breakdown
we specialize in breath of the wild and
tears the kingdom content so let us know
what the like for everything else gaming
though keep it here on Gamespot
thank you
foreign